today on the matt walsh show the media
goes wild over a supposedly major
scandal involving ted cruz but i think
they're focusing on this
non-story for a different reason also
five headlines including nasa's
successful mission
to mars school board members caught on
camera insulting parents and
the white house attempting to appease
the people who want
student loan forgiveness plus our daily
cancellation i'll read the comments and
much more today on the matt walsh show
you know the fact is that most people uh
have a balance on their credit cards
with a higher interest rate than they
would prefer i think
you know you're probably in that
situation uh i
i'm in that situation a lot of us are in
that situation it's pretty common thing
and that's why we all should be looking
at lightstream it's easy with a credit
card consolidation loan
from lightstream to get that situation
under control rates start at just 5.95
percent apr with auto pay and excellent
credit
you can get a loan from five thousand
dollars to a hundred thousand dollars
with absolutely no fees
you can get your money the same day as
soon as you apply
it's it's that simple lightstream
believes that people with good credit
deserve a better loan experience
and that's exactly what they deliver you
know i've i've seen
lots of people we've all we've all seen
people maybe been in this situation
where debt is preventing them from
moving forward with their lives moving
forward with their career
doing all the things that they want to
do and
you know to really live that that
american dream
and that's why lightstream is here and
lightstream
can help us just for my listeners apply
now to get a special interest rate
discount
and save even more the only way to get
this discount is to go to
lightstream.com
wallace that's l-i-g-h-t-s-t-r-e-a-m.com
walsh subject to credit approval rates
range from 5.95
apr to 19.99 percent apr and include 0.5
auto pay discount lowest rate requires
excellent credit terms and conditions
apply
and offers are subject to change without
notice visit lightstream.com
walsh for more information so perhaps
you heard about the big political
scandal that
broke yesterday this was major news big
big deal the media was going crazy over
it it was all
that anybody was talking about on
twitter there were calls for
resignations and investigations was it
was a big big deal right
massively important story at least
that's what i have been
assured repeatedly and loudly over the
course of the past 24 hours the scandal
get ready for this if you haven't heard
yet
the scandal is that uh ted cruz
went on vacation with his family that's
i'll pause right here and let you
collect yourself for a moment because i
know it takes
a minute to recover from hearing
something as shocking as this
yes uh ted cruz went on vacation i'll
say it again so that the severity of
this situation
can sink in uh i repeat ted cruz
went on vacation why does this matter
why is it important why should it garner
all the headlines and uh
and so much controversy well you know
you'll have to ask somebody else
frankly because i don't see it but it
but it does matter
that's what i'm told it matters a lot
you should care you must care
now let's let's back up um and let's
let's try to figure out why we should
care so much about this we'll
back up for a minute as the story goes
ted cruz was spotted at the airport
thursday morning with his family
boarding a plane for
cancun this is scandalous supposedly
because
uh texas is in the midst of a crisis
with millions of
of its citizens without power and
stranded because of the winter storms
as the scandal broke and texas democrats
called for his resignation about it
and every media outlet turned the whole
thing into uh pearl harbor
cruz announced that he would be
returning immediately from
cancun and that he was only going there
to escort his family
implying that he'd always plan to to
bring them and then turn around and fly
back and come back home
he later admitted though that he
actually cut his trip short that he was
planning to go for the week or however
long and he decided to turn around and
come back
that night the new york times had an
exclusive report
featuring private text messages between
cruz's wife
heidi and that and her friends and they
publish these private text messages
here's the tip here's the
the times here's what they reported like
millions of his constituents across
texas senator ted cruz had a frigid home
without electricity this week amid the
state's power crisis
but unlike most mr cruz got out fleeing
houston and hopping
a wednesday afternoon flight to cancun
with his family for a respite at a
luxury resort photos of mr cruz and his
wife heidi boarding the flight
ricocheted quickly across social media
left both his political allies and
rivals
guessed a guest at a tropical trip
as a disaster unfolded at home the
blowback only in testify intensified
after
mr cruz republican released a statement
saying that he had flown to mexico quote
to be a good dad
and accompany his uh daughters and their
friends he noted he was flying back
thursday afternoon though he did not
disclose how long he had originally
intended to stay
text messages sent from ms cruz to
friends and houston neighbors on
wednesday revealed a hastily planned
trip
their house was quote freezing as ms
cruz put it and she proposed a getaway
until sunday
ms cruz invited others to join them at
the ritz carlton in cancun
where they had stayed quote many times
noting the room price this week 300
a night and it's good security um
the text messages were provided to the
new york times and confirmed by a second
person on the thread who declined to be
identified
because of the private nature of the
texts okay
so that gets us up to speed on the
controversy
now a few things here number one
this is not a scandal okay
there there's no actual reason why ted
cruz should stay in texas
he's not going to be pulling out his
toolbox
and going to fix the power grid himself
is it a good look
to leave is it good optics no obviously
not
it was a political blunder a political
mistake
but that's another way of saying that
that there's nothing
actually wrong with taking his family to
a warm place it only looks
wrong it's not actually wrong it just
looks bad
so if you want to slam him for for doing
something that looks
bad uh if you want to hit him for being
politically careless
then fine but if you pretend
that there's some deeper scandal here
some actually corrupt behavior involved
in this guy taking a
vacation at cancun then you're being
absurd you're being ridiculous
in fact to hit him on the optics is to
admit that's the point about
optics if we say that something is bad
optics
from a politician what we're saying is
it's not actually
bad it just looks bad but we know it's
not actually bad well if you know that
it's not actually bad then stop
pretending like
stop acting as though you think it is
um you know that said he obviously was
not planning to fly with his family down
to cancun and then turn around and come
back
as he seemed to imply initially so he
shouldn't have implied that
so he's handled this badly there's no
question about it still it's not a major
scandal
or a scandal at all it's a gaff okay
there's a difference between
a gaff and a scandal a gaffe is when a
politician does something that looks
really stupid and bad
but there's no corruption no crime
no real unethical behavior taking place
so it's a gaff number two given that
this is not a real scandal
publishing private text messages with
cruz's wife
and her friends is scummy behavior
almost as scummy as whatever
quote-unquote friend
uh sent the text to the media in the
first place
imagine what a scumbag you have to be to
do that you've got your neighbor
inviting you on a trip uh and
and what do you do you immediately
contact the new york times
to throw her husband under the bus now
there may be a scenario where it would
be ethical for the media to publish
text messages between a politician's
wife and her friends
there may be a situation where that
would be ethical if there is
this is not that situation a trip to
cancun
is not that situation maybe if there was
criminal behavior taking place and you
had text messages that proved it then
then okay
that might be a reason to publish them
this is not criminal behavior or
anything close to it
so there's no excuse to publish text
messages
number three people on social media
especially on the left have been drawing
comparisons between this
and the democrats like newsom who went
to restaurants or hairdressers during
the lockdowns
um and many were claiming that this
thing with crews
is is in fact worse somehow than
the stuff with uh nancy pelosi at the
hairdresser or nusam at the
at the restaurant or uh uh the the mayor
of
chicago going to the hairdresser saying
that
that at least it's on par if not worse
the cruz thing that's that's the claim
which is utterly ridiculous the outrage
over newsom
and others it wasn't that they were off
having a good time during the pandemic
that's not the problem okay nobody cares
if they have a good time
i don't care if they have a good time or
not that makes no difference to me the
scandal
was that they were doing what they had
forbidden the citizens of their state
from doing they were breaking their own
rules
and laws and policies they were passing
rules
saying you guys cannot do this and if
you do it will fine you will arrest you
and then they turned around and did that
thing that's the scandal
and that's a real scandal that's real
corruption that's abuse of power
so that's the difference so there you
have a scandal
as opposed to a gaff from cruz
uh from cruz at best bad optics not an
abuse of power
it's not cruz violating laws that he
helped to pass or any other law
he's not violating any law or rule at
all in fact to equate these two things
is obviously misleading in the extreme
number four most importantly however you
feel about
cancun gate you should understand why
the media was focusing so intently on
this
you can argue that it was a bad thing
for cruz to do a stupid thing
but you cannot reasonably or credibly
argue
that it deserves all the headlines and
the attention that it got so why did it
get that attention well i submit that
probably had something to do with this
the times union the paper in albany uh
several
hours before the big cruz news broke had
this report
quote uh the fbi and the u.s attorney's
office in brooklyn have launched an
investigation that
is examining at least in part the
actions of governor andrew cuomo's
coronavirus task force in its handling
of nursing homes and other long-term
care facilities during the pandemic
the probe by the u.s attorney's office
in the eastern district of new york
is apparently in its early stages and is
focusing on the work of some of the
senior members of the governor's task
force according to a person with direct
knowledge of the matter
who is not authorized to speak publicly
um
okay so
there is an fbi investigation there's a
lot more to this report by the way you
can go to the times union and read about
it
there's a fbi investigation into andrew
cuomo um the governor of new york
who was hailed as the covet hero now
he's being investigated by the fbi
for a scandal an actual scandal that led
to the deaths of thousands of people
right as news of this investigation was
beginning to spread suddenly the major
story is
ted cruz going to cancun
i don't think this is a coincidence now
you could argue that even without the
story from from
cuomo the media would still be making
hay with the cruise
quote unquote scandal because it's a
republican and it's their opportunity
to embarrass a republican and that's
probably true too i think all of these
things are related
what we do know though is that the
crew's story does not deserve the
attention that it got
and yet yeah you go on social media and
you find even conservatives
who are joining in the outrage bandwagon
willfully being manipulated by the media
the media wants you to see this as a
much bigger deal than it is
they want you to see they are telling
you to see it as on par
with newsome they want you to focus on
this instead of the cuomo thing
and even now so many conservatives are
happy to go along
even now are happy to say well okay if
you tell me this is what i should care
about
it's absolutely absurd and by the way
just to just to
reiterate reinforce what i said at the
very top here
um you know
ted cruz is not going to be going and
fixing
the power grid now maybe what you want
him to do
is to do the photo ops and to go out and
to hand out hand out cups of soup or
whatever
um and that's what a lot of politicians
in fact do in these circumstances
why do they do that you know if there's
some sort of natural disaster
and the politicians are there themselves
personally
you know handing out the soups and
waving to the cameras why are they doing
that
is it because they care about is it
because they care about their citizens
no it's because it's a political
opportunity
they don't act nobody needs them in fact
it's it's better for them not to be
there
because when they're there then there's
there's there's media there's security
it's actually better logistically to not
have them
they can delegate that i'm not saying
that a senator should be doing nothing
in response to a crisis like this in his
state
but he can delegate it he can get on the
phone privately make phone calls send
people out to do things
he doesn't need to personally be there
himself and in fact it's probably
better all things concerned if he's not
the reason why the politicians
themselves
personally want to be there is for the
photo up
i don't understand why so that i
understand why they the politician wants
to do that
why do citizens want that from their
politicians
why do you want a politician to do the
photo up
i don't need that personally
it's not something that i need to see
and i'd prefer if not
if we didn't see it
now if there's evidence that ted cruz
even behind the scenes is doing nothing
whatsoever hasn't delegated anything
hasn't made any phone calls
hasn't sent any of his people out to uh
you know to go hand out the soup and to
go to the warming stations
you know if there's evidence that he's
done absolutely nothing behind the
scenes then fine you can get him on that
but i don't see any reason to assume
that all we know is that he was not
originally going to be going himself for
the photo op
now he is going to go for the photo op
and i guess a lot of people
feel more comfortable and they feel
comfortable now oh thank god we've got
the politician doing the photo up i
don't get it
being manipulated by the media let's all
uh let's all try to be better than that
let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
you know ready wise has been a sponsor
on the show for a long time so i've been
telling you about ready wise and their
emergency meals and the need
to be prepared for emergencies for a
long time and um well
this past week we've seen unfortunately
an example of the kind of emergency
that can happen and where you
if you don't have these kinds of
emergency meals then
you you would wish you would so this is
the time to get prepared for it
for the next time something like this
might happen ready wise is the leader in
emergency food supplies they have
emergency meals
freeze dried fruits and vegetables for a
convenient on the go to on-the-go
nutrition plus they have new adventure
meals for hiking camping and other
outdoor activities
ready wise makes being prepared simple
and affordable you can order online have
nutritious meals shipped directly to
your doorstep
ready wise meals are proudly made right
here in the usa so you're supporting
usa you're supporting american workers
at the same time ready wise makes being
prepared simple and affordable you can
order online have nutritious meals
shipped directly to your door
when preparing our meals all you need is
four cups of water
uh water doesn't even have to be hot
it's as simple as that you simply
pour the food into the water you stir
you cover after 15 minutes
it's all ready to go you shouldn't have
to sacrifice taste and nutrition with
emergency food ready wise
uses the finest ingredients and latest
food preparation technology to ensure
optimal
taste and freshness each recipe is
crafted by a team of chefs to provide
delicious nutritional meals
i've had the food myself and i can
report that it is uh
it is very good with a 99 satisfaction
rate and millions of products sold
ready wise has quickly become the leader
in emergency preparedness
and when the time comes power goes out
when something happens
and you know your perishable food is
going to perish
then you want to make sure that you're
prepared and that's why right now is the
time
to get ready-wise this week my listeners
can get 10 off at readywise.com when
entering walsh
at checkout or by calling 855-475-3089
ready wise is a 30-day no questions
asked return policy so
there's no risk in taking the initiative
to get you and your family prepared
today
that's readywise r-e-a-d-y-dub
promo code walsh to get 10 off yeah i
wanted to mention i know i'm
way behind the times here but i finally
saw the movie i watched with my wife a
couple nights ago we watched hillbilly
elegy
and i i hadn't read the book but uh and
i'm sure the book was better books are
always better in the movies
in almost every case but i finally saw
the movie
which is you know that's the movie based
on the book written by jd vance
about his experiences and uh i think
most of it is set in
kind of middle class working class ohio
and with his with his family and his
mother struggled with drug addiction
kind of his memoir
and uh i thought it was a a really solid
movie it's not
it's not going to be in my top 10 of all
time but it was a solid movie with
powerful performances
a couple the performances were weak some
of them involving kids you know you you
can't really hit the kid actors for not
being the greatest
but um particularly the the
the main adult actors glenn close
amy adams really powerful performances
um
and overalls just a solid well-made
movie and a well-told story and telling
a story that
uh that many millions of people can
relate to unfortunately
especially having family members that
struggle with drug addiction and that
kind of thing
but then you go to rotten tomatoes and
the critics
absolutely panned this movie they hated
it
and it's it's this is one of at least
from the movies that i've seen this is
one of the greatest disconnects i've
ever seen between
uh what the critics say about a movie's
quality and the actual quality of the
film
because in reality this is a solid like
b plus
good movie like i said not a cinematic
classic but a solid really good movie
critics panned it and i can only assume
whenever you see that
critics are panning it but it's a good
movie meanwhile the audience and the
audience reviews
are um it's kind of like run hide fight
our daily wire movie but the audience
reviews are like 80 90
while critics are giving it a 25 30
percent anytime you see that there's
always a reason behind it it's always a
political reason and in this case i
could only assume that the reason number
one is that jd vance is
you know i think basically right wing
slash conservative-ish
um i don't i'm not overly familiar with
his politics but i think that's kind of
where he lands
and uh and also i think the other reason
is that
the movie kind of makes the white
privilege narrative seem absurd because
here you have a story
um a a not unusual a pretty typical
story about
you know white a white family in a white
working class neighborhood and when
what they went through you can't watch
that movie or read the book and come
away thinking well yeah those people
were privileged
in fact the the the guy in the movie jd
vance himself who eventually
becomes if you want to say privilege
because he goes to yale and becomes a
lawyer
but uh he had to earn that he had to
work very hard he didn't start with any
advantages he had to
claw his way up and go get that and i
can only assume
that's why the critics didn't like it
but if you haven't seen it i will give
it my
recommendation okay number one nasa's
perseverance rover landed on mars
yesterday um yesterday afternoon to
begin its
search for signs of life on mars i don't
think they're looking for
uh intelligent civilizations let's say
but um they're looking at least for
signs of uh that there was life at some
time
at one point on mars they were aiming
for and hit
a big crater called the gizero crater
which was a big lake
three billion years ago and they're
thinking there might be evidence that
life
used to be in the water there evidence
of of organisms
billions of years ago so this thing
traveled 293 million miles
okay think about that 293 million what
293 million miles
this the craft did over six months
and it hit not only the planet it was
aiming for but the specific
crater that it wanted on the planet
meanwhile it takes me like six tries to
toss a skittle in the air and catch it
with my mouth that's
so an incredible achievement overall the
rover i mean not me and the skittles
um we've already seen some pictures from
the rover it's uh it's easy to take this
for granted and we
we've seen a lot of pictures of this
kind but even so
we're looking at pictures of another
planet that's a that's a
remarkable and profound thing we should
stop and appreciate that
of course these pictures come in and the
first thing that happens
is that the internet makes memes out of
them and they photoshop
bernie sanders into the
photo of of mars which i understand i
get it
but still damn it internet can you be
serious about something for five minutes
anyway well i guess we should say thank
you to nasa thank you for sending that
rover 290 million miles so that it could
send us back some awesome
meme templates because that's all that's
all that we're going to use it for
number two you want to hear something
really insane maybe you don't but i'm
going to play it anyway this is
democratic representative
katie porter i want you to listen to her
take on
the school closings and when she thinks
we can get the schools back open again
listen
well i think there's two issues one is
how do we get them back i think the good
thing that president biden has done is
he's pushing
he's pushing he's asking the right
questions he's setting deadlines and
he's mobilizing agencies
like the cdc to issue guidance guidance
that then senator kamala harris and i
called for
back in the summer time the other part
of this though that i think we're not
planning enough
is about what's going to happen when
they do all go back to school and that's
where senator michael bennett from
colorado and i have authored a letter to
the department of education
pointing out to them that we can't just
put kids back
in school as if their learning and
social and emotional development has not
been severely interrupted
and this problem is particularly acute
with regard to math and science
education so it's a workforce
issue and a workforce development issue
as well
so did you get that we can't put kids
back in school until we figure out
how much harm we're doing to them by not
putting them back in school
okay so we can't put them back in school
until we figure out how much damage
we're doing by continuing to not put
them in school
that's such a classic government answer
you know
we got first before we uh before we stop
doing this thing that we're doing
we have to let's file some reports and
do some uh
you know have some commissions to look
into see how much damage we're currently
doing
by the thing we're we're doing and and
then and then we'll figure out if we
should stop it and go back
so that's that's the that's that's the
strategy
uh more audio related to the school
issue i wanted to play
first here's the report from the daily
wire it says california parents are
calling for the resignation of the
oakley
unified elementary school district board
of trustees after board members made
disparaging remarks about the parents in
an online meeting
in a video obtained by fox news school
board members can be heard cursing and
claiming that parents with children at
home
are using marijuana at increased rates
the board members believed that they
were alone and were unaware that they
were broadcasting the meeting live to
parents
uh let's listen to this went on for
several minutes but let's listen to just
a little
snippet of this just to encourage you
yeah people it's easy to hide behind a
screen
and put it but when you're face to face
with people
it's a whole different it's a whole
different ball game
well what's funny is that uh she's
friends with
who i went to title tower
it's like whatever i wasn't doing
anything bad i could i really
i honestly don't care about that part
but you know what
are we alone yeah
if you're gonna call me out i'm gonna
[ __ ] you up
sorry that's just me
you know they forget that there's real
people on the other side of those
those letters that they're writing yes
we're real community members we have
kids or have known kids that have gone
to these schools
right having a vested interest in this
process
and they don't know what we right behind
the scenes and it's really unfortunate
that they
they want to pick on us because they
want their babysitters back
so she calls the parents the b word says
she's going to f them up which
no she won't and then there's a comment
about how the parents
only want their babysitters back and
that's that's all that school is
and that's this is revealing in a
certain way but another way it's
it's not not surprising that this is
what the school board
thinks of parents this is the
antagonistic
um view that the hostile view that they
have
of of parrots and this is what they
think of their own job and of school
itself is nothing more than
than babysitting
another thing to keep in mind about uh
as
as maybe you consider going into next
year do you want to
get your kids back in a school system or
do you want to try out homeschooling
maybe a reason to lean towards the
latter number three more from the daily
wire it says a baltimore activist who
had spent 18 years in prison
then turned to efforts to stem violence
in the city has an idea
for combating massive numbers of
homicides in the city
the idea is this pay people not to kill
others
tyree morehead who was jailed at the age
of 15 for 18 years after second degree
murder conviction told fox 45 i can
relate to the shooters guess what they
want they want money
i've talked to these people i've seen
the shooters it's a small city i know
who the hustlers are
i can't stop the shootings no one in
this world has proven
has proven to stop the shootings not
even the church what but what we can do
is put them in compliance fox news
reported that
as of 2019 he had painted this is the
the activist had painted nearly 200 no
shoot zones throughout the city in 2020
the city eclipsed 300 homicides for the
sixth year in a row
while recording more than a thousand
shootings so this uh moorhead this
activist
along with advocating that we pay people
not to kill others he's also going
around the city
and painting actually like like spray
painting i think he has a permit or
something to do it i'm pretty sure but
uh any any paints no shoot zone around
certain areas of the city
i don't know why i don't know why nobody
ever thought of that before well i guess
we have thought about it before it's
kind of like the
gun-free zone no shoot zone
and so i guess the hope here is that if
um
some you know two rival gangs were about
to get into a fight over
over turf over you know whose corner
belongs to whom
and uh maybe they're about to start
shooting each other and then they would
look and one of them would see
the pain the sign on the wall saying no
shoot zone
and they would say hey guys look it says
no shoot zone but yeah let's not do it
here no shoots on
let's respect the no shoot zone and uh
what do you say we
reconvene down the street if there's not
a no no shoot zone
that's the hope that it will work that
way i don't know if it actually does
work that way i tend to doubt it
um more from this it says i i trying to
read where he
explains what how this program would
actually work
um
but i'm not sure where that is anyway
that's that's the basic idea maybe that
maybe
all the details aren't quite fleshed out
yet we haven't ironed out all the kinks
but uh
the idea is to pay people not to kill
each other
hey i'm you know i if we're doing that
i would just like to say that i have
gone my whole life and not killed
anybody
so i don't know how much i'm owed for
that
you know i've i've gone my whole i've
never killed anybody i never
robbed anybody never set anything on
fire
so every day that i've not done those
things i guess i'm owed some money
we can laugh at this idea but it yeah
it's certainly no more absurd than
defund the police or any of these other
ideas
because what you can't get around
is the idea of punishment
um justice segregating
here's what you at at the end of the day
probably the only thing that really
works for a lot of the really bad guys
the kinds of people who would think
nothing of going out and just killing
somebody
because they want to sell drugs in the
same corner or killing someone you know
going to rob a liquor store and just
shooting a guy
so that you can steal 87 from the till
those kinds of people
the only thing that really works is to
segregate them from society
in a prison cell that's that's what
works
that's how you keep whether or not they
can be reformed while they're in prison
if they can great most of the time they
can
but the first job of the justice system
in the court system
is to protect society the innocent
people
to make sure that the next liquor store
clerk is not shot in the head
and that means you take these people and
you put them in a cage that's what works
number four at his town hall um a couple
days ago biden was asked if he would
increase his student loan debt
forgiveness plan from ten thousand
dollars to fifty thousand dollars and
here's how that conversation went
student loans are crushing my family
friends and fellow americans
me too the american dream is to succeed
but how can we fulfill that dream when
debt
is many people's only option for degree
we need student loan forgiveness beyond
the potential ten thousand dollars your
administration has
proposed we need at least a fifty
thousand dollar minimum
what will you do to make that happen i
will not make that happen
it depends on whether or not you go to a
private university or public university
it depends on the idea that
i say to a community i'm going to
forgive the debt
the billions of dollars of debt for
people who have gone
to harvard and yale and penn and school
with my children i went to a great
school i went to a state school
but is that going to be forgiven rather
than use that money
to provide for early education for young
children who are come from disadvantaged
circumstances but
here's what i think i think everyone and
i've been proposing this for
four years everyone should be able to go
to community college for free
okay so he's trying to take an
unreasonable and bad idea which is
student loan forgiveness and find
and find what the most reasonable
version of it
but that's not good enough and so the
white house has experienced
a lot of backlash from from the left on
this people like alexandria case or
cortez
who say that's not good enough you need
to bail out 50 000
and now the white house is trying to uh
navigate their
their way around this and here's jen
saki trying to finesse
biden's answer a little a little bit a
little bit the following day here she is
listen
the president said pretty clearly that
he doesn't think
he has the authority to cancel fifty
thousand dollars in
student loan debt today senator schumer
and warren
said in a statement that they were told
the administration is still working
on figuring out if it has the authority
so if your lawyers would determine that
canceling this is legal
would the president go ahead with this
and if not why not
well first on last night uh last night's
town hall for those of you didn't see
the whole thing
he was reiterating his previously stated
position which is he doesn't favor fifty
thousand dollars in student loan relief
without limitation and he used some
examples of
the types of schools or when it should
be reimbursed or
refunded he said previously that relief
above 10
000 should be targeted based on the
borrower's income based on the kind of
debt in question
public schools versus private schools
graduate schools versus undergraduate
obviously there's a lot of
considerations
at play yeah the the problem for the
white house is that anything
other than we're simply going to forgive
everyone's student debt
up to up to at least 50 000 anything
anything outside of that is not going to
be acceptable
to their own base to their own
constituents on the left
and it's it's it's a terrible idea like
we talked about a few days ago uh
you know i mean we we could we could
spend another hour going through
all the reasons but a couple quick
reasons number one fifty thousand dollar
student loan forgiveness uh that is a
bailout make no mistake about it that's
a bailout for
the upper class it's not it's not
primarily poor people who have
fifty thousand dollars of student debt
uh that they're dealing with this is
upper-class families many of them many
of whom have the
means to pay it back uh they might not
want to it's not fun to pay it back but
they have the ability to do it you know
i
i have plenty of debt myself not not
student loan debt but i've got car
payments i've got mortgage
i've even got my not my own student debt
but my wife's student debt that i've
been that i have been
paying um for the last 10 years
it's not i don't like it it's not fun i
don't enjoy doing it
um we we we can do it
and we do pay it because we're the ones
we took on the debt for the car or the
house and my wife took on the debt for
the student loans so we pay it back not
fun i don't like it but we do it
the point is this is
we hear about a lot of the extreme
scenarios um people who are
destitute working for jobs they've got
80 000
of debt they're trying to pay back and
there are situations like that there are
also a whole lot of situations of
upper class families with a lot of
student debt
that they chose to take on and they do
have the ability to pay
it back even if not the actual student
then the family i mean if you're if
you're a uh
you know upper class parents and you
pushed
your kid to go to college
and you know in large part because
because
you couldn't imagine any other situation
and you know you didn't want to have
kids who don't go to college
because you'd be embarrassed by that so
you push them to go to an expensive
school
and now they've got all this student
debt taken but
that's that's on them to pay back and
also you if they can't do it then you
should do it
because i i agree you know 18 year old
kids even if they're legal adults
they don't understand what they're
getting themselves into
that's the part of this student loan
debt forgiveness debate
where i guess i agree with a lot of what
you hear on on the left
that part i agree with that
the people taking on this debt at 18 or
19 years old just out of high school
they don't understand what they're doing
and we can't really expect them to
understand
the difference though is that for me
the blame falls on the parents
okay and it falls on the schools it
falls on the actual universities
somehow in all this conversation about
student loan forgiveness
the schools themselves escape punishment
escape blame
they get off scot-free and they can
continue doing with all these plans they
can continue doing what they're doing
right now
which is to pay is to charge exorbitant
amounts
for an education that is not worth that
and they're doing it by bilking these
kids
so the government wants to come in and
fix it but you're not really fixing the
problem not fixing it for the future
so i put the blame primarily on
parents who push their kids into this
should be talking some sense into kids
into their kids
they should be saying to their kids
listen you don't need to go to a
four-year university right out of high
school take a year take two years get a
job
work a little bit save up some money get
some life experience
you can always go to college anytime you
go to college under 40 if you want
you don't have to there's no reason to
go to college
right out of high school there's just no
good reason to do it
whatever you want to do with your life
you don't need to go
right from 13 years of grade school k
through 12
right into more school take a couple
years
what's the downside who what is it who
are you racing
you got to make sure you get that
college degree before before who
who who are we raising
i know yeah when you when you do go to
college in most cases you can go to
community college for two years
it's a lot cheaper transfer those
credits to the four-year institution
why not that plan i think there are a
whole lot of people
millions of kids who are going to
college and shouldn't be going at all
because they don't need to
go and they're going to ultimately end
up doing something with their life where
that college degree
is useless so there are a lot of people
in college who don't need to be there
and there are many more who are in
college and maybe do use the degree
but they didn't need to go right out
right out of high school they didn't
need to pay as much as they did and they
didn't need to go to four years of a
four institution they could have gone to
two
so um whose job is it to communicate
this to the kids
it's the parents and it's the schools
the public schools the grade schools
should be telling the kids this the
universities should be saying this
the university should be saying to an 18
year old kid who shows up
and says yeah i want to go to your
school uh i don't know what i want to do
with my life i have no idea but uh
you know yeah i'll i'll plunge myself
into debt just so i can go to school
right at right at the age of 18 and you
know be with all my friends so we can go
and party
the school should be saying no you know
what you not right now maybe go take up
i know the schools will not say that
because they're not going to turn down
the money but that's my point
they're the real villains here so
i don't i don't think the government can
solve that problem there should be real
accountability with the people who are
actually at fault
schools parents they're the ones that
fall uh okay
and also if we're if we're assigning
guilt and fault then i would also
say a lot of employers a lot of
employers who require
a four-year degree for jobs that don't
actually need it it is a
it is an artificial necessity
there are jobs where you really need the
the extra education
obviously if you want to be a doctor or
an engineer or an architect or something
or a lawyer you know then you need that
extra education so that is an
actual need there are a lot of other
jobs where
entry level you're going to be sitting
in a cubicle typing into
a computer all day and whatever you need
to know about the job
you're going to learn on the job that's
the case for so many other
millions of situations but even in those
situations
the employers require the degree for no
real reason other than it's just an
artificial need it's a way of
weeding out applicants it makes it
easier a little bit easier on them
because they're too lazy to do the real
work and find re and find candidates who
um who have the skills and the ability
for the qualities needed for the job
and so as a way of kind of weeding out
kind of dwindling down the pack they
throw out all the people that don't have
college degrees
they deserve some of the blame too okay
number five dolly parton sent out a
statement yesterday and the statement
reads
uh let's see here she says i want to
thank the tennessee legislature for
their consideration of a bill to erect a
statue of me on the capitol grounds
i'm honored and humbled by their
intention but i have asked the leaders
of the state legislature
to remove the bill from any and all
consideration given all that's going on
in the world i don't think putting me on
a pedestal is appropriate at this time i
hope though that somewhere down the road
several years from now or perhaps after
i'm gone
if you still feel i deserve it then i'm
certain i will i will stand proud in our
great
state capital as a grateful tennessean
uh yeah
dolly parton get a lot of credit for
this and for good reason i i like that
too
dolly parton may be and i bring that up
because i've i've raised the question
before especially after the death of
alex trebek
uh who was who was a universally beloved
american and i know he wasn't really
american but i'm i'm claiming him as our
own as an adoptive
son of america um so
he was universally beloved and now and
now he's tragically gone
so how many people do we have left
famous people who are universally
beloved across the board
both political isles no matter where you
stand ideologically
everybody loves you there aren't many i
think dolly parton may be one of the
only ones dolly pardon betty white i
don't know
keanu reeves maybe but
this is one of the reasons why it's it's
it's smart too
i think it's a it's a it's a good idea
in general with with statues we know
statues have become contentious issues
and i'm all about building statues to
our historical icons i'm all about that
i think it's a great
great thing to do uh but you should at
least wait until they're dead we could
call this the joe paterno rule
um it's it's even if someone is
you know towards the end of their days
and they're and they're older and you
know
they're going to be dead in the next 10
15 years anyway
uh even so it's not a good idea to build
the statue while someone is still
alive just wait until they're gone
then you you alleviate the risk of
having to tear that statue down if
things go
go wrong all right we're gonna go now to
read the comments this is from april she
says
hold up matt you're 35 interesting
uh no actually i'm 34. i said yesterday
on the show that i'm 35 i'm actually 34.
i said i'm 35 because i can't remember
my own age and my wife was not here to
tell me
usually when someone asks me how old i
am i turn to my wife and say how old am
i and she tells me
um and that's not a joke either that's
not a bit i really do forget my age
already so i'm and i'm what am i right i
just i'm 34. i'm 34 and i'm already
forgetting how old i am
i cannot imagine what i'm if i make it
to 70
it's gonna be bad news uh jess says
about the adhd thing you know it's an
actual disorder right there's a physical
difference in our brains we have a lack
of dopamine that makes us lethargic and
inattentive and twitchy and a lot of
other nasty things
adhd isn't just hyper or inattentive
there is a model brain as you put it
and we don't have but yes i agree a lot
of young kids probably get misdiagnosed
well jess first of all i don't know that
you're right about a lot of what you're
saying here
um the the
the issue of whether or not adhd is
reflected physically in the brain
or rather how exactly it's reflected
physically the brain that is a
very controversial contentious uh that's
something that scientists neurologists
and neurobiologists have been looking at
for for decades now
i i i don't think it's nearly as simple
as you're putting it
uh it's kind of like people will will
sort of blindly say that
uh well depression is a chemical
imbalance in the brain
and that's that that's the common
narrative because that's what we've been
growing up when we were told growing up
that it's a chemical imbalance well
that's actually not
true um there's there's not a lot of
evidence for that so
which isn't to say that it's not
reflected in the brain it's not as
simple as you put it
uh that's the first thing second thing
though
is um it it doesn't actually matter to
me
whether or not it is reflected in the
brain let's just say sake of argument
there is such thing as an adhd brain
which as i told you if there is an adhd
brain i've got it
i'm i am i am uh
a model case for adhd i can tell you
that right now
now um so let's say there is such thing
as an adhd brain
okay the question though
is whether our brains
should not be that way so what i would
put it to you is
okay maybe there is an adhd brain who's
to say that your brain is not supposed
to be like that
you say there's a model brain well on
that one i can surely tell you you're
wrong
uh there's there's there's no there is
no one single brain
that we can pull out of someone's head
and say this is what your brain is
supposed to look like
now we could do that on a real general
sort of
basis okay we could speak very generally
about
how the human brain functions and what
it looks like but when you get into the
real specifics of it
everyone's brain is different because we
all have different personalities
different proclivities different
experiences different emotions
all these things everyone's brain is
different and all our brains are going
to be different also in ways that
we can't even fully detect yet because
we don't have the science for it
so only in the most general sense can
you talk about model brains
when you get started getting more
specific and talk about individual
personality traits
i don't i don't think that exists
i don't think there is a model brain all
the way down to the personality types
there is no personality trait or way of
thinking
that we can point to and say that's the
right that's the right personality
that's the right way
of thinking the adhd brain
i would say or the adhd personality adhd
type
i would say is not a disorder it's a way
of thinking it's a mode of thinking
now that mode of thinking doesn't work
very well in certain circumstances
in other circumstances it does there are
other circumstances where having the
quote adhd brain
is going to help you
but just because it doesn't work and
cert it doesn't work as well in certain
circumstances
that does not mean that it is disordered
that's my point
that's why i say my issue is with the
disorder part of it
i don't think that it's it's it's right
to call it disorder i don't think
there's evidence for that
okay it's not like a neurological
disease like dementia
okay we can look at dementia and
obviously say
that this is a disease that your brain
is not supposed to do that
we say that for one thing because we you
could you could physically see it
destroying the brain and it will kill
you
it's a pretty pretty good giveaway that
that's not how the brain is supposed to
be there's something wrong here
that's on the case for adhd the person
with the adhd brain
can can function very well in society
they can be
wonderful well-adjusted people they can
be very successful
all of that it's just in certain
circumstances they're going to struggle
who is to say that the that the you know
that every person is supposed to
succeed in those circumstances
um let's see let's see we'll go to one
more
kenneth says no matt you lost the
aquaman question you can't just name a
character and have whoever you're with
pick a power and oh yeah he does just
pick superman every time
someone who can go back in time hey you
win super strength hey you win flight
you win etc
you're a cheater you need a full
confession of acknowledgement that you
are a game scammer
shame well kenneth you i went through
this yesterday didn't you see me
i pulled up the evidence okay i've done
my research you didn't do your research
the question was what superpower would
you like to have i said i'd like to have
the superpowers of aquaman
okay then my wife says oh he wants super
strength
what does aquaman have super strength
so that is i fairly won and i was robbed
and the fact that you would sit here
and and take the side of the people who
have scammed me
and rigged the game against me when i'm
the victim
is just more reason why you are banned
from listening to this show how dare you
how dare you sir we talk about the
problems in the education system all the
time we talk about it again today it's a
common theme on this show because it's a
it's
a major problem in our culture today and
you know
you look back and you kind of ask what
the heck is going on in our schools
critical race theory choosing your own
gender climate change
doom and gloom the attack on american
history all this stuff this left wing
nonsense is now taught from kindergarten
through
grad school and it's turning kids into
left-wing activists it's brainwashing
millions of kids
because millions of kids have to attend
these schools and be subjected to it
that's why we need to fight back
my friends at prageru know exactly what
we're up against and they're doing
something about it right now several of
us here at the daily wire are featured
in prageru videos prageru knows how to
educate
millions of young people like no other
nonprofit they've been doing it for a
long time now prageru is taking on k-12
education
with prageru resources for educators and
parents known as prep
if you're a parent or teacher you need
to join this group today
this is the most powerful community of
conservative parents and educators in
america
now's the time to join you can join prep
at prageru.com
forward slash prep that's p-r-e-p with
prep you'll save our children from this
leftist brainwashing best of all you'll
join thousands of members already
working together to make sure education
reflects our values
we need you on our side the strength is
in numbers we have the numbers now we
all have to come together so you can
join prep today
by going to prageru.com forward slash
prep
and as i'm sure you know actress gina
carano has been uh making her way
through
the news cycle recently she was the star
of disney plus she was
uh disney plus mandalorian she was
canceled for being conservative
and uh and usually that would be the end
of the story someone's canceled that's
it we don't see them again we don't hear
from them
but that's not how it works now because
the daily wire is fighting back and
that's why we just announced a movie
deal with gina
she'll be developing producing and
starring in an upcoming film that will
be released exclusively to daily wire
members
we've all said it conservatives need to
do more than complain we need to
actually engage
and fight and that's what we're doing
now and that's why we need you disney
plus has eight billion dollars to throw
around
uh we have you and so that's why we need
you in the fight to take back our
culture go to dailywire.com
subscribe and use promo code gina that's
g-i-n-a
to get 25 off of your membership today
now let's get to our daily cancellation
now today for our daily cancellation it
really pains me to do it i hate to do it
i don't want to do it uh but i have to
once again
cancel my wife she is now the most
canceled
person on the matt walsh show beating
out aoc though the contest
remains close the reason i'm canceling
her is this tweet here that
she sent out yesterday this is what she
tweeted she says
the moment when you can't stop laughing
because matt tried to run and slide with
the storage lid sprayed with pam and
instead makes a hard stop and his face
bounces off the snow covered
off the snow-covered cement and then
there's a picture of me
on the ground clutching my side and in
obvious great agony
now a few things here first i was using
a storage lid and a cooking spray
uh because we don't own sleds of
spraying down a
lid with cooking spray because we don't
own sleds as i explained a few days ago
the stores around me all out of sleds
too i had to
stop on my way home on um wednesday at
the store
uh for some necessary supplies like
diapers and of course bread and milk
and i i noticed that all of those kinds
of supplies this was like in an ice
storm and i'm
on my way home from the hotel where i'm
shooting this week and it's in an ice
storm roads are untreated as i've
documented
i had to stop and i go in
and all of those kinds of like diapers
milk bread
you know all that kind of stuff that's
all fully in stock
but what the store is out of is beer and
sleds those are the two things
that it's out of and i and i had this
moment of pride in my community
that um we all have our priorities in
order
you know running out in an ice storm to
buy beer and sleds
that you you've got to make sure you
have the essentials now
that's first thing second my wife's
recounting of the events
is accurate i did indeed take a plastic
storage lid
uh spray it with cooking oil and then
attempt
to slide down our cement driveway and i
did in fact take a running head start
and then actually
dive this is what i did okay i want you
to understand this
i made a running head start and and dove
intentionally
chest first onto the cement and ice
all of these things happened why is my
wife canceled for that
well because for one thing i probably
broke my ribs
i was in pain i'm not even necessarily
joking about having broken ribs i really
might have broken ribs i just refused to
go to the doctor for it
because i don't have to explain this
story and um and
but all my wife did was was laugh and
take pictures
like she's literally standing above me
taking pictures
laughing while i can barely breathe and
then my daughter
as i'm on the ground my daughter runs
over and jumps on top of me she actually
yells
yay jump on daddy and just jump straight
on top of me with my broken ribs
it wasn't until several minutes later
several minutes until all the pictures
had been taken
and the laughter subsided for a moment
and then and then my wife asked me if i
was okay
only then which for the record i wasn't
not physically or emotionally
so that's the first reason she's
canceled the second reason
is that she allowed me to do this in the
first place
and the escapade on the on the concrete
driveway was right after
i went sledding down our ice-covered
stone steps
i mean what sort of self-destructive
idiot behaves this way
and i'm a grown adult apparently 34
years old
who does this more importantly though
what sort of wife
sits back and films while her husband
behaves this way
see i take no personal responsibility
here at all i'm not responsible for this
i am not responsible for my own
behaviors wives should know
that husbands are usually quite rational
when it comes to most things but when it
comes to balancing
the risk of physical harm against the
reward of having fun
we have a short circuit in our brain
something goes haywire wire and it does
it just doesn't work it's not our fault
it's a condition we're born with it we
can't do anything about it
this is why this all falls on my wife
who is not only morally but i think
legally liable for my behavior i could
sue her for this i really could and i
still might
this is almost as bad as the time a few
years ago when i went sledding off a
massive ramp uh
we went to the this a school to go
sliding down this hill and some kids
that made a ramp that they were
snowboarding off of
and i went sledding off of it and i
nearly broke my tailbone and yet again
guess who's standing off on the side
laughing her ass off
while mine is broken into seven pieces
that's right my wife so you're starting
to see the pattern here
you might say that the pattern is me
acting like a [ __ ]
and yes that is one pattern i don't deny
that but the other pattern is my wife
exploiting my idiocy for her own sick
amusement
and that's why my wife is once again
canceled and that's going to do it for
us today
uh we'll leave it there have a great
weekend everybody stay safe out there
godspeed
[Music]
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling our technical
director is austin stevens
production manager pavel vladowski the
show is edited by danny d'amico
our audio is mixed by mike coromina hair
and makeup is done by nikka geneva
and our production coordinator is
mckenna waters the matt wall show is a
daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021 hey everybody
this is andrew clavin host of the andrew
clavin show
you know some people are depressed
because the republic is collapsing the
end of days is approaching and the moons
turn to blood
but on the andrew clavin show that's
where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way through the fall
of the republic with me
andrew clavin